these seconds here these 23 seconds here
we go
1:35 there are a lot of you here a lot
of you here oh here we go here we go
here we go 135 135 have entered a little
over 18 rating and why not why not give
this one a whirl it's been so long since
what it's been so long since I played in
the tournament I feel the urge to try
and get a win to try and get a win
Castle here we go 94 I still have that
up my sleeve it's gonna be kicked okay
now it's quite appealing if I take him
out this is game over because I take
tonight and then flop with a pin I think
that's a mistake
I'm gonna take the night how do I take I
think I take with the Queen I'm on the
rook I am on that rookie okay
push that pot I want to push further and
break down this diagonal so I'm up the
exchange if I push there's gonna be
night here
I just I'm gonna sack I'm gonna give
that material right back just so I can
get these bishops working like crazy
like crazy
first I'm gonna inconvenience the night
kick them back a bit and then I'm gonna
push forward again how do I recapture
just keep my queen around here in a
castle Queen side and now there's a
problem keep pieces pinned attack them I
should have been considering this attack
pinch pieces they're down a time back
determined I should have been looking
more at the time who has 6 2 people 6 6
5 whoa right out of the gates the bird
is the word
the bird is the word in this one take
that Knight right away it's a pin that
guy structural damage let's jump my
knight out right here with tempo I'm on
that Bishop I'm also on that pawn I
don't want to take that bishop should
just consider Queen here right away I
get some tricky stuff where's the tricky
stuff whoa really gonna do that no way
all right let's let's try to attack here
shut my knight right in here it's a bit
scary like dark square bishop
get out of there my knight is reinforced
you wouldn't take that pawn no way I
don't believe it okay
I'm on the clean on the coal that I
thought they we're gonna get a piece
back could take this there's no rough
move here my nights a monster it's open
this position up want to get this beef I
break in b5 is in break this down keep
pushing keep pushing that pound move
yeah did shut my knight in around the
rook why do I do that this is getting a
little too crazy yeah I didn't need to
go for this why am I going like this
it's just so foolish no it's not this is
a good diagonal this is deadly now this
is a deadly deadly position unavoidable
what unavoidable discovered check Queen
is cooked okay they're down on time back
to Charlie 12:12 12/12
whoo my goodness what is going on in
this tournament there are a lot of
people playing a lot of people playing
in a lot of high scores early I get
scared when I see that I get scared when
I see that woman uh-huh take my night
that's really check oh I got to do that
now I'm in a pin can't be fun let's take
that with a check they could take the
pawn I'm in a pin they could still take
the pot I'm in a pin I don't want the
night to get here oh they they were in
creme of mode I'm gonna Castle queenside
I have condition if I control a five I
control the game I also have this skewer
in mind not afraid of that oh yes I am
yes I am afraid of that let's get the
Queen's off before something bad happens
I'm on the rook I'm I have a full rook
full rook full rook
double up the rooks are off cut the King
off and run run like the wind blows run
like Forrest Gump back to tournament 12
2015 12 12 12 12 12 12 a lot of 12s
let's try Botvinnik setup now I'm not
gonna have that okay hang on try and get
in d4 push my opponent around building a
Center I'm looking to do that
I almost played my king to f1 that gonna
be a pain I'm in a fork f3 oh man
structural damage big time oh they have
structural damage let's get rid of that
bishop scaring me get out of there Queen
oh maybe there's force queen of five
tricky Forks be afraid be very afraid
you know what I'm not afraid of that
dark square bishop I have him under
control what I don't have under control
is this light square bishop so to get
that out of there and now we do the
classic the classic rook up and over
everybody's favorite everybody's
favorite thing to do
rook up and over King g8 I could have
been oh the Queen is trapped actually
she's cooked King here rook here is
still just trapping the clean how do you
like that decisions know that the light
square bishop was the more annoying one
this structure alone cancels him out so
it's the light square bishop my first
thought was actually throw the Queen out
to g4 let's go let's go the queen is
cooked if she's captured I could be
throwing in a check do that just for fun
if the King goes here we're looking at
mate the King goes back to the h5 queen
g4 stuff they reside back to tournament
30:23 2000 K who the mr. mayor mr. mayor
is in the house the Sicilian is still
around yes it is can't get enough of
this this leads to some quick kills
exactly what you need in these war zones
quick kills I shouldn't even provoke
that okay this if you Castle you're dead
well that's cooked because this is a pin
and then a win pin and annoying the
Bishop was needed prior to Castle you're
very important detail to reinforce that
central point d4 so now I'm looking at a
checkmate by way of h4 and h5 Knight g3
and after the capture on g3 made a risky
efore this guy's new at school he's the
new kid at school take that okay I have
the F file to play with I'm not taking
the bishop if it's challenged on e6 I'm
gonna play here cuz I want to kick the
knight eventually sure let's do this
okay pawn push throw my knight on this
square right here this is a giant pest
okay that's I'm up material now I want
material I should have done in a
different way I could have picked off
that pun I might want to do it next if
the knight recaptures there's Queen
check on b6 however let's block with the
Queen okay I'm a little bit afraid a
little bit afraid my rook has to stay
there okay this is a dangerous and a bit
on the dangerous side Queen trade cleans
our intention it's easy to miss the
lateral movement it's not missed though
it's upon is passed I'm gonna back them
up with this guy here we go okay my
opponent's Bishop is cooked these pawns
keep rolling they're monsters they're
monsters I could have just pushed let's
do it now
rook takes pawn it clean I don't take
the bishop okay they resigned back
determinate did they resign one or the
other they resigned her they were down
on time c5 Jimbo Jimbo 21 21
okay looking for a Grand Prix as my
opponent if they take I'll be not a good
idea I want to kill the bishop I want to
get in c4 kill this Bishop is the plan
he's killed I'm to take tour away from
the centre because I want to vacate that
square for my pieces it's a pin this
night and I'm a look to pile up piled up
I also to conveniently defend this pawn
and now I take here with check and after
the pawn takes structural issues I have
f4 available let's come back to
reinforce my son of this Bishop is still
dead jump my knight and I could have
done this that would have been a fork
now it's there it take take right here
this is still reinforced with what my
knight
I'm on this square now watch out for me
looks like a fun check to go forward
breath maybe not let's come over here
still covered this Knight is a bit
annoying
I'll have that covered they missed it
here no matter what they resigned back
to tournament no I don't need a shirt oh
that little button is conveniently
placed isn't it it's conveniently placed
it gets in the way to my back to
tournament gets it away I was it back to
tournament button conveniently placed
maybe though mistakenly maybe they will
mistakenly do what don't mistakenly
click on that button see about the cool
shirts and buy one pins this Bishop is
in rough shape and now what do I want to
do I want to make sure this Bishop
doesn't do anything I want to I want to
control this square that was the main
idea I was a good little or maybe not
cuz now I have a pawn oh they missed it
they missed it probably resigned here
right no
okay let's just I'm up a full/queen
full/queen full/queen
more than just that now whole house is
falling back to tournament 72-54 40 to
40 37 a lot of time left
a real lot I thought this was Mario at
first more c5 let's try d5 let's try a
gambit a gambit oh it's not entering a
gambit land I'm gonna stop d4 just
create some imbalance just to get some
imbalance you're gonna give me this
there's no good it wouldn't be any good
discoveries there it's back up now
they're gonna hit me with a pin now
they're not now I have a connected
passed pawn and let's just try this it
looks very appealing just open up the F
file okay now I'm gonna get G 4G 5g for
this is a trump d4 pawn get out of
sneaky stuff keep my bishop right where
it is my knight cannot be challenged b4
b5 is my only concern if the Queen moves
I'll play a5 to put a halt to that but
the attention is quickly going to turn
over here and now the night is kick
which mean my queen is freed up believe
jumping out to just h4 is the most
aggressive post looking for g3 and then
made on each two if pawn push I take and
there's probably some tactic against f2
I could sack and maybe get my other
piece involved let's push I'm also
vacating the g4 square for my light
square Bishop made threats that's a
deadly fork I'm not going to take the
rook yes I am yes I am I want to keep
the cool now let's just take 12 seconds
this is gonna be a what oh they did that
there's no smothered mate is there for
sex that dr. Mike yes mother mate that
tricky Knight that tricky night they
resigned back determined that game
wasn't gonna finish 90 56 55 16 minutes
remaining
efore for the win caro-kann oh no no no
oh that's not a good idea I don't think
because now I have a strong center and I
think this turns out to be a bad
a bad French a bad French because that
pond that sea Pont took two moves to get
to that c5 Square where normally it
would take one and everything else is
the same
so castle I think this pond push
eventually is what I would like to get
in take with my night and then of my
dark square Bishop although it could be
challenge I want to be cautious of this
Square and I have it covered now I'm
still looking at this pond push let me
get all my pieces working first and then
this is next with f6 to fall off takes
Knight takes is devastating there might
even be some tactics on this square and
I think I'm gonna go for it just throw
my night in here with check if the Queen
goes are actually the cleanest to go
here well that can't be good
I'm on a clean stone I feel like it
could still be taking this and some made
on that each seven square just take the
Queen up back on that I'm also looking
at f6 let's do this
well they didn't take okay
have Forks and everything now Forks and
everything that's me back to tournament
110 110 90-72 15 minutes remaining
um what's something different and also
aggressive no like this different and
aggressive let's try that alright let's
kick that night around let's push again
pile up on that weak link my knight and
my queen it's not going anywhere
Queen Queen and Bishop I could hit that
Queen okay dark square Bishop I'm just
going to do this that that's not a
threat my bishops out look working I
feel like I could take on d5
okay I'm out I'm back to being on this
where's the mate there's got to be a
mate very soon
the queen is defended threatening this
next I got to be careful of this square
pinion and win attack pinch pieces
attack those pin two pieces the Queen
ghosted a phantom and a hitter with rook
ad C just gonna take still looking for
mating ideas night and Bishop are
controlling these three squares made
threat coming up tonight has to drop
back but then there's tricky stuff like
happened to me in that Simon the King is
cut off 15 seconds
tricky checks filed by night here rook
takes its matin to what takes rook it's
check and then mate trying to lure them
away get out of there
no that works picks up some material
okay let's make sure that that Knight
isn't going to kill me he's boxed out by
my bishop and hunt him down hang on but
the king could have maybe moved over
better just go faster back to turn it
there down on time 131 1090 89-86 13
minutes remaining
just a minute pair up is it going to
pair up is the big is the big question
might be a quick a quick win by way of
error okay okay I guess it's a I would
like to be player there I like to be
able to put a primo ven but that's not
happening
where are these other where are these
other games I don't want to turn away
from this 12 minutes give me the air and
give me points where am I at point wise
whoa 130 129 120 come on I'm losing
ground
it's no fun when you're being chased
from behind there who likes being chased
from behind raise your hand raise your
hand look at a one point difference
ten point difference oh man it should
have already come on let's go
oh there we go up here here err give me
points give me points yes oh well I got
ten I'll take ten though I'll take ten I
will take ten alright let's open stuff
up let's push my opponents night around
and let's build a center my has to be
challenged soon let's just throw another
pot up in another one avalanche of ponds
a tsunami of ponds and that's where it
stops now I get some more development in
hang on I don't want the Queen to play
here I don't want it to be a pest and
now jump my nighty and I want to keep
these pawns flexible maybe I'll go h4
maybe I'll do something else
pawn push I don't want the night to get
to g5 or a c5 I don't want a castle Oh
Bishop here it would have been lovely it
would have been lovely when they oh man
I missed that it's just still okay do
you realize it's still okay Knight here
I think is available I don't want to try
to have a space advantage let's open
this up can we open this up please oh do
they really want to do that did I really
want to do that well I want to jump my
knight in here did this rook here I'm
really committed on this side there's no
entry points though Knight here looks
pretty good and I'm on the clean I just
want I just want to get this pawn out of
here this pond is actually acting as a
very good defender for my opponent if
he's take that's that's gonna be game
over soon very very soon drop back with
check and then come back to give check
pawn push it's just me right away well
actually if the King ran away I would
get the Queen that's why they did they
did that 160 149 140 that was me
at final position Mart Oh
oh I didn't mean to do the bird mean I
didn't mean to throw the bird on that
what I'm sorry I'm sorry
might be some tricky stuff on the C file
take a couple times
I'm blocking in my deep on but I'm
looking for some crazy attack starting
with maybe this starting with this would
they really take that part are you gonna
take that part that night I want my
knight on f6 I really take that that
can't be right mate threatened I'm on
the knight age seven Knight right here
is gonna be deadly I think there's a
mate actually yeah there's a mate coming
up very soon natan one two three you see
it you see the mate threat it's no
longer there Queen takes four seed seven
okay Jade get that dark square Bishop
kill the knight what's this rook doing
his dummy he's a big dummy so I'm gonna
kick my king up I kind of just taken the
night take free pieces would you double
up on the G file this is the G file
isn't it yes it is this guy's going down
he can't be tolerated I don't want to
deal with this these bishops are
monsters
Oh how long has that been there I think
as soon as the knight move that had made
on a chain finally I was probably there
for three moves 180 169 160 130 a very
very close you have to keep winning you
have to keep winning come on you also
have to pair me up let's go eight
minutes 38 seconds here we go let's see
what my opponent throws at me
let's try King pawn rarely do I do this
rarely no thank you no thank you
let's pinpoint f2 whoa my opponent's
pinpointing f7 why would they ever do
that
why would they ever do that
okay but will freeing out my bishop to
come up with temple as well if I moved
it a bit sooner just get rid of that get
developed I don't want to take that
bishop no way no way you don't have
rookie one yet you still don't have
rookie one well it's not good at least
on the Queenie I am on that Queenie its
Castle misdirection otherwise there
might be some tricky stuff if I line mic
hang up on that diagonal there might
have been there might have been I should
probably just take that I'm on this I
feel like capturing that I'm on it again
my queen is active my Knights ready to
jump out I'm on the rook and now this
pond has gone far enough
Wow counter-attack get this Knight he's
a very reckless looking I was ready to
take with the pawn it wouldn't have been
made but it looked like it was made no I
need to guard my light squares so my
queen is there to stay she's there to
stay that's not working
clean doesn't recapture with the check
that was what I was just check I really
have five seconds oh my goodness are you
kidding me oh my goodness I spent so
much time
where did my time go I should be able to
still get this does that mean does this
mean no no no just take care next and
that's made finally I'm glad I looked at
the clock
oh I'm go I just trying to be like
finding the most accurate the most
aggressive moves my goodness man I need
I need warnings anymore
I need warnings I need something to be
flashing up saying move move your time
is ticking your time is ticking f floor
is not a good idea after 96 because I
need to stop Knight d4 I'm pretty sure
it's reinforced my son I want to get
rook d1 this night might be trapped in
some cases I want to get g4 in if I move
my Queen the night ends up attacking
yeah let's do this the night is kind of
cut off Queen III is a trap I'm
threatening the night Queen III I think
f6 might be needed but there's may be
some issues here all right let's keep it
closed I'm not so keen to exchanging
pieces no I just want to get developed
Bishop g2 weak piece right here on c6
maybe I get the rook one day jump my
knight right in here maybe just build up
my Center first these guys is a big
logjam here of pieces they can't move
having a tough day at the office
Knight d5 here next I could have just
done that right away here we go pawn
recaptures this Knight is sidelined
build up my Center probably h5 h6 ideas
maybe even g6 could afford to sack
material just to open some lines now
these pawns are ready to roll
they are definitely ready to roll h5
next and then Knight here
okay this Bishop is crunched Bishop is
definitely crunched and I can't actually
okay yes I could do that I want to get a
pawn here and then what next my bishop
on c6
they're down at time back to terminal 2
22 20
I lose on tiebreaks because of what if
it did come down to that why would I
lose on tiebreaks because they have more
games than than me I need a quick win
are there any quick wins in town where
are they
pom push before Knight c3 allows the
clean to give check on a5 and then picks
off e5 ok so I have the bishop pair my
opponent it doesn't have oh yeah
two bishops versus no bishops that's a
problem isn't it can i really get this
no that's so that's 2k vanish that is to
cave Manish what am i doing I'm spending
too much time all right take one of them
I guess ok I'm gonna hang onto them then
come over here what am i doing take I
need to free up my light square bishop
now my bishop could see I'm ok with the
Queen trade I am ok with the Queen trade
get my rook active I should just take
that pawn oh no oh no no no no did you
see that that was you know what you know
what I call that you know what that is
the adobe flash gambit everybody's
everybody knows about that I should just
take in the pond just chop back 16
seconds oh oh where's the meat
where's the meat where's the main
there's the main unavoidable no look
here hang on then I do this don't have
any time I'll just do this anyhow
they're gonna lose on time they didn't
have any time back determined to forty
two forty two minutes fifty two forty
two forty seventeen games and 16 games
and I got I got to get a quick win well
this could be a quick win my opponent
waste of time but they could get that
one
- check I don't want to trade Queens no
way okay
I want to keep some in bounce just gonna
Castle Wow
that's crazy town that is crazy town
right there okay um let me just take
this I should just take in that pond
keep pens
oh very weakening clean here I want that
night to move queen deeds free clean
here
I want that night to move Bishop here oh
another clean and the bishop now
cleaning the bishop
I shouldn't allow I shouldn't given up
my dark square bishop oh I got another
piece where are the where are the forks
where are those forks on the night
where is the mate better not get back
ranked mated let's check and then this
is made I had to I know it's not me over
here oh ok to sixty one twenty to sixty
to sixty ah I gotta play the chest GM
the Carol kind of know the perk the pre
move are the mouse lip perk that was the
mouse lip perk the mouse lip perk is
what we had there get rid of that night
maybe what am i doing let's get this in
let's throw a check-in my nights back to
working maybe I'll just take that I need
to get my pieces working you defend that
pond there's some tricks over here get
that night out of my house
oh if thanks for playing they called it
soon ah
second place confetti let's close out of
that oh I didn't even I didn't get a win
even if I did get a win
I had the games they had on almost
server update I know it's a computer
thing remind me later um even if I got
that win it wasn't enough 282 6248 246
225 there were some really top heavy
scores there the two in the 200s 250 ish
area and high 200s very very good
tournament